1 2 3 4
[Musique]
blamont gardant 6h30 t'es levé tune en
cours de perché
tu vas avoir du français ensuite des
mathématiques et tout va bien la tuque
ce sera le matin y'a l'élection salle de
bain pour que prendre un petit vin
histoire de se relaxer avant d'attaquer
la journée et puis l'après midi tu auras
science et vie ce sera trop beau quand
tu penseras à colas et or orange il me
rend très pleins de clips tout ça sur
ses vieux team qui campe avec leur temps
et le soir en rentrant manger tout ça va
pas le temps tu as lu ras la console
monique et des crimes ou lol et à 1h du
mat tirade de faire des passes par des
lance patates et des duels paix
je tire de beauté
et par dessus sa journée
et des bas comme que je sois plus
entrants
[Musique]
waouh
pas plus
mme marois film et y allier la tradition
pour la personne qui filme safir 2 3 4
je palais aux colonnes je parlais du lpg
pas les marathons comment de poids léger
je parlais plus quand les rocket
launcher quoi mon fric en colosse est
vraiment le sniper on ne peut pas les
marqueurs finale comme ça a vraiment à
coeur
[Musique]
moi j'ai rigolé du parlement toutes les
soirées moi j'aime color ma coups durs
que j'ai
moi j'aime j'aime que la peine de
m'appeler
j'aime bien décrocher
moi j'aime ça je suis sidéré j'aime
collage
wahaha
[Musique]
beaune de google avec un clic
quant à jari qu il faut cliquer
messieurs dames d'afrique
pourquoi on tire la pause